oh my goodness I got to be honest I'm
not ready to say goodbye to Rick Grimes
and it sounded like last season you
weren't ready either can you talk to me
about the decision to extend your stay
from season 8 to season 9
it was an impossible decision I mean and
I think that because the season was
going so well I was enjoying it and we
just been at Comic Con I just wasn't
ready and and I you know I spoke about
it it was like but you have to make if
you have to get people ready for it and
I had I realized very quickly that I
wasn't so yeah I went for one more the
fans about how we say goodbye to Rick
Grimes and did you have any say in his
send-off well I mean I think it was
about day two of filming I and I asked
Greg Nicotero who was shooting the
episode how many pints of blood does a
human actually hold because I'm not sure
I'm gonna make it through the credits
see what was your reaction when Andrew
told you it was time to go that rat
bastard you know I knew before everyone
else knew to be honest we kind of had a
little pact if one of us would need the
other one you'd leave so I was I know
way in advance I was really bummed I
tried to talk him out of it but I get it
he's got two little kids and he lives
way over in England so I understand I
can't be mad at him and I talked to him
out all the time but still what a
bastard how did you guys send him off we
had a nice little celebration for him
and I and sort of like a roast thing
Andy Lincoln day it was very fun it was
filled with a lot of love a lot of
laughs a lot of good stories apart
heartfelt goodbyes and
a really good final episode to me about
this roast that you guys had at his
send-off party
were you a part of yeah I was part of it
I did a whole I did a whole thing as
negan but as his character in Love
Actually with a poster board and how
much I loved him and all the yeah it was
great it was great it was great we love
me we love him and we're all gonna miss
him he means a great deal to the show
[Music]
[Applause]